and Hannah clear this whole business
about women in America being oppressed
is laughable every every year hear that
woman that Obama was in office
he would come out and talk about how
women make X number of sense on their
dollar compared to men so if that were
true you would fire all your men hire
women and pocket the difference uh there
are more women now in college than men
the numbers of women entering medical
school and law school equal the number
of of men graduation stats too right
graduation stats women live longer I
mean it 90 of the people behind bars are
men I mean where how where are they
oppressed this is the only uh instance
in history that I'm familiar with of an
oppressed class being more likely to win
custody battles being more likely to
receive more lenient sentences crimes
more likely to vote more likely to
receive a higher education more likely
to be considered for uh Elite programs
such as being admitted into a stem field
based on their application it's really
man a difficult kind of impression
that's a pressure peel me off some of
that yeah exactly